Consider the car.
Cruise, commute, sit in traffic, take a road
trip, make out in the back seat, break down,
get pulled over, push the pedal to the metal,
race, chase, crash.
The car has a ubiquitous place in cinema.
But why is cinema obsessed with the automobile?
One of the most fetishized objects in film,
the car is represented more often, and more
diversely than any other form of transportation.
But to call the car transportation, is to
misunderstand its role in film entirely.
The car movie, and the large car chase action
set pieces are probably what leap immediately
to mind when thinking of cars in movies, and
you could make a whole video essay about those
things alone.
But the space the car has carved out in the
movies is much larger than that.
The car is a costume.
A character’s car can tell you a lot about
a them before they even speak.
In Nightcrawler, Lou’s car is the main way
we’re shown that he’s gaining success.
In Boyhood, the car the father drives tips
us off the the fact that he’s the “fun
irresponsible dad” and when he trades it
in later in the film, it’s an indication
of personal change.
A
car can be an extension of a character, in
The Darjeeling Limited the brother’s attempts
to retrieve their father’s broken down car
from the garage on the way to his funeral
illustrates their dysfunction in the midst
of their grief.
In The Big Lebowski, … the destruction of
the Dude’s car parallels the out-of-control
spiral of the story.
In Taxi Driver, Travis’ Bickle’s Taxi
is a high horse for him to sit upon.
It is what separates him from what he calls
the scum of the street.
The car is a location.
The interior is a dramatic stage.
The characters can all face the audience and
the scenes that unfold inside a car are as
varied as the humans that occupy them.
This forced intimacy is instant fodder for
what cinema loves to examine.
Though equally interesting to the prying eyes
of the film camera are the inescapable silences,
and the arguments.
Cars trap us in a box with other people who
can’t leave, at least without hurting themselves.
There’s the tension of being forced into
the back seat with a few unsavory characters,
or the joy of being crammed together with
some buddies.
A car can separate a character from their
surroundings.
It’s a portable space we own.
It’s a representation of our individualism,
of our personal freedom.
In the car you get to go where you want to
go, your hands are on the wheel.
You feel you control your destiny.
You get to put your music on.
That space provides a, perhaps false, sense
of privacy shelter from the outside world.
Criminals feel free to talk business.You
might try to hide in one from outside danger.
But that space can be invaded, revealing how
fragile a shell of protection it really is.
And the freedom the car gives us can leave
us vulnerable.
The Car as a location includes more than just
the interior though.
The archipelago of cars in a parking lot are
personal islands for people to gather around
for conversation.
Leaning at someone’s car window puts you
on the line between stranger and friend, waiting
to be welcomed in, or evaluating whether you’d
even want to enter.
A character might remove someone from their
car as an attempt to remove that person from
their life.
Or drive away to achieve the same effect.
The car can symbolizes youth grasping for
maturity and trying to enter adulthood.
In Rushmore, Max’s constant invasion of
adult’s cars is an image of his attempts
to be a part of their world.
In Lady Bird, Lady Bird’s need for others
to drive her around is an image of her dependence
and then eventual gaining of independence.
The car
is violent.
The trauma of a accident has been used endlessly
as a dramatic tool.
A visual shorthand, it’s a favorite of the
flashback.
Vandalizing a car isn’t an attack on an
object, it’s an attack on the person who
drives that car.
The car itself can become a way to act out.
In the Godfather, there is a motif of violence
in association with cars.
Perhaps representing how changing times are
presenting challenges for the Mafia, a car
is a dangerous, vulnerable place to be for
a mobster.
Maybe the car harnesses some more primal instinct
for the thrill of the chase.
It’s a mundane and common place part of
our lives that can suddenly become a vehicle
of thrill, a weapon, and gadget, or a detective’s
tool for investigation.
Enticing to the camera is the movement, the
endless motion of the landscapes found outside
the windows.
There can be a dramatic inevitability to this
movement, a feeling of something that can’t
be undone.
Locke, a movie set entirely in a car during
a single trip, uses the finality of each mile
driven to build tension.
But that movement can also come to a screeching
halt, leaving people stuck, unable to get
where they want to go, creating some of the
conflict and obstacles every character needs.
The obsession runs deep.
Even in our fantasies we cling to the image
of the car.
We use it to traverse through time.
Even when society has been utterly destroyed,
the car remains.
We consistently humanize the car and imbue
upon it a personality and self, making it
one of the few pieces of technology we seem
to consistently anthropomorphize in our media.
Scenes in cars have been shot in a variety
of ways throughout film history.
But there emerges what I see as two primary
approaches.
In the first, and most common, the camera
assumes an omniscient presence around the
vehicle.
Impossibly floating in and around the car
to provided the best compositions.
The second approach, rising to prominence
through the French New Wave, places the camera
in the car, the viewer just another passenger.
But filmmakers have gone to great lengths
to film the car, it presents a challenge,
but one that filmmakers are obviously willing
to overcome.
I think the diversity of things that a car
can be or represent, makes it a perfect tool
for filmmakers.Certainly, Hollywood’s location
in a city where cars are a necessity has impacted
the presence of cars in the movies.
LA writers write cars into films because cars
are a part of their lives.
The world’s empire of film had been located
in a city with public transportation, maybe
things would be different.
Cinema is the technological sibling of the
car, born of the same era, neither knows of
a time without the other.
How will cinema be effected by the way the
car changes?
Will the arrival of self-driving cars be like
the cellphone?
An obstacle that writers will have to learn
to write for, something that challenges the
conventions of how transportation is displayed.
Whether or not it continues to be, the car
has been a vital piece of cinematic storytelling.
In
a film a car is never just a car.